At first the experiment was uneventful, the teacher delivered the smaller
shocks in the shock generator whenever the learner made an error. However, as
the shocks increased in intensity, many of the teachers became very
uncomfortable and unsure about continuing. When the teachers expressed to
Milgram that they didn't want to continue, Milgram would tell the teacher that
the experiment must continue. You must continue with the experiment. So, every
time the teacher tried to ask Milgram to stop, he told them that they were
unable to do so and they needed to continue delivering the shocks. While the
teacher was administering the shocks, he heard some preprogrammed responses
from the learner. For example, at 90 volts, the learner would yell ugh. And its
at these times when the teacher became uncomfortable and would tell Milgram, I
want to stop. And recall, Milgram would say, you must continue, the experiment
must go on. At 150 volts, The teacher would hear the learner yell "get me out
of here! My heart's starting to bother me. I refused to go on. Let me out!".
Here again, the teacher will become uncomfortable and tell Milgram that he
wanted to stop. In each instance, Milgram reminded the person that he had to
continue with the experiment and that he could not leave. Finally, when the
volts went past 330, the teacher would hear no response from the learner at
all. And this implied that the leaner was either unconcious, or worse. Remember
when Milgram asked those experts how many people would go up to 450 volts?
Well, they were very wrong. In fact, in his results he found that 65% of the
participants went all the way to 450 volts. Also, there were no differences in
the sexes, meaning men and women were equally likely to go all the way up to
450 volts. Interestingly, adding the yelling of the learner at 150 volts, where
he yelled, 'Let me out of here. I don't want to continue,' did decrease
obedience from 100% to down to 83%. It's important to point out that the
participants were debriefed, and told after the study, what the study was
actually about. And they were reunited, the teacher and the learner and the
teacher could see that the learner was actually never harmed. Milgram conducted
a series of studies in this area and changed some of the variables. For
example, he changed the attire of the researcher. It turns out that people were
more likely to obey when the researcher was wearing a white lab coat, than when
the researcher was more casually dressed, like here. In one experiment, he
changed the proximity of the teacher and the learner, and removed the barrier
so they could see each other. In these situations, the teacher was much less
likely to go all the way to 450 volts. These are called systematic replications
of the original research study. So, it turns out that there are many variables
that influenced obedience to authority. Now, let's go to Greg to talk a little
bit more in-depth about the ethics of this Milgram experiment.